voilà voir ici est une chienne à leur
gardien
bah c'est out qui a 5 ans mère de
famille elle dit huit petits avec 4,81
les quatre feux même qu'ils soient d'ici
peu partout en france irlande et
distribuées à des ennemis et j'étais
très gentil chèque qui n'a pas le droit
de faire ce qu'a fait en ce moment
d'ailleurs voyez si j'allais chez ingres
un petit à petit et nord tunisien alors
on a fait un grand charme et affective
est très mignonne depuis combien de
temps ici et là ici elle va lui elle
s'appelle ici ici et là depuis vingt
cinq ans votre quatre ans et demi
on a eu tout petit et pourquoi l'appeler
vous ici elle s'appelait elle a même
montré très snob s'appelait ingrid et
s'appelle réellement ingrid offre rascal
et alors il fallait un nom qui commence
par y et en arrivant pour le muc de
l'appeler ici parce que sa commande de
10 noeuds dans mes divas temps ici
l'attend elle comprend qu est-ce qui
s'en occupe ici
c'est un peu tout le monde ment ça en
fait moi je n'occupe pas mal c'est à
dire que quand je suis là je la sors de
la même compagnie elle a pris l'habitude
de matin dans la voiture et elle a
horreur d'être tout seul une chaîne car
je crois que beaucoup d'animaux sont
comme ça mais elle ne supporte pas de
preuves et si jamais seul dans la maison
c'est catastrophique
il se moque et d'après vous sa
préférence il avait requis je suis pas
beau chalet
j'ai l'impression des animaux vont vers
ceux qui s'occupent de sion sont très
simples dans leur bras devant la scène
où elle un rapport et appartements il
semble qu'on les aime et qu'on s'occupe
d'eux ils vont vers vous alors je crois
que dans la famille pour des raisons
multiples pas six mois qu ils en
occupent le plus donc apparemment c'est
moi qu'elle aime le plus fort 11
vous voyez vous passez maintenant
d'animaux chez vous je crois que
malheureusement on apprend à on apprend
à se passer de tout le monde le tout
mais 200 froid je m'en passerais très
difficile
oh
vous allez tourner pour nombre de films
suppose que vous avez quelques anecdotes
gras crois que quand j'étais aux lèvres
mousquetaires avec richard lester
c'était encore une époque où l'avait
modifié un petit chêne cocker et un jour
richard lester qui est absolument
chauffe j'arrivais en coaching de louis
xiii mais pas complet si j'avais juste
et pantalon qu'il montrait jusque là
vous vous clé et je tenais en laisse mon
chien qu'elle absolument la même tête
que moi ont fait jaillir en tête que
l'hypnose et là il m'a regardé il a dit
combien vous allez si vous possédez
votre perruque en laisse on avait deux
têtes absolument vous avez souvent
tournées à l'étranger qu'est ce que vous
en faites et bien j'ai le bonheur
d'avoir une très très bonne amie
productrice de films qui s'appelle
michel debre au cac dont ces grandes
productrices y entend une merveilleuse
amis et quelle maison tiffon en dehors
de paris et qui je crois a la bonne idée
de recueillir fait chier pas mal de mes
camarades comme partons pas ce qu'est la
ligue maison et genre
beaucoup les animaux et alors je sais
que j'ai rencontrés là-bas le chef
jacques perrin sait pas à quel faux
bijoux
vous pensez dans une maison le chien
c'est un élément supplémentaire l
harmonie dans une famille 1 je pense que
c'est bien pour les enfants c'est un
cetain un régulateur formidable je veux
dire on les apprend on leur apprend à
comme c'était en fait qu'ils ont
beaucoup voulu celui là par exemple il
faut qu'ils l'assument quand même ça je
suis très exigeant avec caen qui sont là
je les force à occuper elle sortira et
puis qu'ils apprennent s'ils veulent
s'ils veulent s'amuser avec ils vont il
faut s'en occuper en un chien un chien
c'est une responsabilité
et comme toute la responsabilité il faut
savoir les assumer à quoi attribuez-vous
le besoin qu'ont les gens d'avoir des
animaux chez eux
je crois que c'est un besoin de un
besoin de présence besoin de dpn animal
vous apporte une qualité de d'amour et
de désintéressement rarissime on trouve
pas chez les ch et nos semblables mais
les animaux ont une autre une autre
qualité et puis je crois que c'est un
peu peut-être un besoin de
responsabilité
je crois que c'est important d'avoir un
être vivant qui dépend complètement de
vous et si on est soi même de bonne
qualité ça vous incite à être encore
plus généreux à vous occuper de de
quelqu'un d'autre
quoi je vois c'est tout un ensemble de
choses et puis là et puis la présence la
présence quelque chose qui respire qui
est qui et choquette à côté de vous qui
et c'est presque un sentiment de
sécurité
c'est la vie je crois que c'est bien
d'être entouré par la vie et les animaux
sont une forme de vie
tout à fait extraordinaire et dont
devrions tirer beaucoup d'enseignements
nous